I see a man who would love for the
Chiefs to win a football game this
weekend and then keep going on I sense
me the question which quarterback I see
a man who was part of Modern Family on
ABC I see a man an award-winning man I
see a man is wearing Chiefs gear head he
tells is might tough tough outfit I see
Eric Stonestreet here on the Rich Eisen
show right which quarterback would you
like to see win a Super Bowl ring for
the first time right get to Arrowhead
earlier and you early tomorrow and you
can get one of these apparent what the
first 50,000 fans come to the game
that's what we are I actually forgot I
brought it today and it fell out of my
jacket I'm like where do these underwear
come from that's my mouth all right how
you feeling how's it look all right I
feel good I feel good it looks great by
the way thank you thank you
so covers up my gaping receding oh dear
your preacher of the quarter yeah I got
it should I put that on let me see what
that looks like
that's really gonna keep the hair out of
your eyes
Negi wear the visor on right now by the
ball guys wear visors good yeah I'm
walking out right now there guys we just
split it with mahomes what do you think
it looks good looks good look at the tea
Kelsey back there Travis Kelce when you
see feel-good I've been noticing on your
Instagram account at Eric Stonestreet
just like your Twitter account yeah that
you were like is it Saturday at how many
more nights of sleep to our is required
yeah I'm excited look but you you know
me you know me I come into the season
every season this excited as excited as
I am right now
this year the difference is is it's been
it's it's been justified the whole
season I keep getting more and more
excited so I'm excited I mean I'm a
football fan I'm a Chiefs fan so I'm
excited and I feel good now when you say
you feel like it's legitimate mm-hmm
compared to the Alex Smith years
compared to Trent green years I mean
like what are you talking about here you
know I said on your other show you know
this is a different feeling that I have
I literally said to you I feel like when
it's third and eight I feel like we have
a chance to pick it up when I never have
necessarily felt that confident that day
against the Ravens its fourth and
whatever and mahomes comes across the
field finds Tyree kill for what 48 yards
it happened in that moment yeah I know I
never get gay no I don't feel the
feeling of needing to give up like I
have in the past
you know but I also a measure so I also
know that we're gonna be lined up
against professional athletes and we
have to win we have to win the battles
yeah the cults too right I mean I get it
once upon a time one in five yeah now
eleven and six good quarterback I know
39 touchdowns not 50 is this the team
like if you could have chosen out of the
wild card weekend is this we match up
really well against the Colts I think
for a couple reasons
no one yes our pass rush is very
underappreciated
in the national dialogue and
conversation I know their offensive line
is great but that seems to be you know
what the topic of conversation is if
Quentin Nelson's great I mean he's gonna
be Chris Jones tomorrow see how how that
goes he may win you may not they're not
gonna win every battle every one of them
so I think our pass rush is not being
talked about enough to get to Andrew
Luck and then the other thing that I
don't thinks being talked about that
much is how they're gonna stop us from
scoring 48 points yeah I mean cuz also
Andy Reid coming off of a bye week is
pretty damn good Andy Reid is is his new
new Andy Reid as far as I'm concerned I
love I love Andy Reid I love the higher
I know Philly fans are like yo just wait
and see what he does to you the playoffs
like whatever he's got he's different he
sits on the bench with Pat while the
defense is out on the field and it looks
like they're deciding what they're gonna
get for appetizers I freaking like yeah
I know he's the Andy Reid that we've
mentioned he's out of you know what's to
give he is he wants it and
and and and also when in this world
where we're seeing all Eric Stonestreet
here on the Richardson show for the full
hour by the way eight four four two oh
four rich people and it take your phone
calls will talk things other than Chiefs
it's just in case no no because your
diary football fan there's all that
stuff going on I do want to talk you
know with you Yuri you're a big twelve
guys well Kliff Kingsbury is now on the
National Football League and that's part
of something that we could hit on a
little bit right here because my point
is going to be with everybody looking
for the next Sean McVeigh okay to the
point where McCarthy didn't get hired
Mike McCarthy didn't get hired and Bruce
Arians did get hard but you know what
you're gonna get with him Andy Reid kind
of reinvented himself here
he reinvented himself in Kansas City but
still had some of the same things that
Eagles fans were given you agree for
about clock management what happens in
the playoffs mahomes is the game changer
he is the game changer for read for this
franchise for people that might be
thinking a trapdoor is getting set to
open an arrowhead to kick off divisional
playoff it's the mahomes it's the
mahomes effect it's hat it's you don't
want to put all the pressure on the kid
but he happens to be I think a guy that
can handle it I think he's very poised
yes out of his element poised like it's
impressive but that's what great play
does it elevates everyone around you it
it elevates the tackles it elevates the
guards the wide receivers to hit their
routes right and I think no doubt that
it's elevated Andy Reid I mean I think
he has brought his game up and you know
everybody's looking for the next Shawn
McVeigh I'd say you there is no Shawn
McVeigh without Andy Reid and you need
to be looking for the next Andy Reid and
somebody asked me if I'd rather have
Shawn McVeigh or Andy Reid I'm gonna
take the 200 get the guy that's one 200
games in the NFL before I take the guy
that probably will win that yeah and
that's why I'm wondering why Eric the
enemy didn't get we're looking at him on
the screen right here why he wouldn't
get a sniff I mean where he did but he
didn't get hired it doesn't look like
well I don't take someone from the Andy
Reid tree right now well yeah it's
worked out for the Eagles and it's
worked out for the Bears you know yeah I
mean I'm hoping it's because a
combination of Eric not wanting to leave
yet I mean we don't know that how super
interested he I don't know hmm maybe he
wants to see this through and get a
little more under his belt and then go
dominate what is that this that he's
seen through what is it this this how
much you willing to talk about how much
you willing to put out there through the
mouth gate you know here's the thing I'm
willing to put it all out there knowing
that there are just people that exist to
make me feel bad when you know what I
mean like you what you know people don't
mostly understand is how that people
wake up every morning to go on to
Instagram or to Twitter to make make
like make us feel bad for putting an
opinion out there or a thought and every
you know I wear my passion for the
Kansas City Chiefs loud and proud
knowing full well that in the past it's
very documented that I have been
disappointed um but again that's that's
taking something away from the people
that lined up against the Chiefs can
beat them they're professional athletes
the Patriots are the greatest moment
probably in NFL history yes we've lost
to them because they're great Tom Brady
is great well and and I can also say
this too though about your I guess
fandom and I will put this out there I
don't know if you're where Kris Brockman
but there's many people from the
football world who are fans of Modern
Family humorous fans of course family up
the flow chart of the National Football
League resides the Commissioner of the
National Football League
yep who you've you you've referred to as
the goods Reds so the goods has invited
you to come to the Superbowl correct
well yes he made that invitation a few
years ago and I said not until the
Chiefs were in it and make no mistake I
have been reminding him of that
invitation this season and I oh you have
oh yeah of course
I've does he I mean there's some fans
though that just wouldn't even put that
out there because then there's a there's
that has nothing to do with how well do
block and tackle and throw the ball
tomorrow and next week and potentially
in the Superbowl like
I mean putting that I mean I'm a fan but
I'm not like weird like just like the
people that say oh well the Chiefs of
this history it's like Mitchell Swartz
tweeted out it's like I'm pretty sure
that you know when Patrick mahomes was
in high school and the Chiefs were last
loss to the Colts has nothing to do with
right you know tomorrow I think it's a
said okay so you you put it out there
yeah put it out there I just told him I
said look I hope you've got a suite in
Atlanta because I'm gonna be on your
pullout well I think he'd so you mean
sweep not in the stadium I worried about
where I'm gonna stay if I get to go like
could you imagine by the way I think I
think I don't want to say it make some
calls I think the good says it is a
pull-out couch yeah I would think so I
mean that sounds like a great sounds
like a great Neil Simon play all right
we've got phone calls people are calling
it yeah or 204 rich we'll take a break
we'll come back we'll take phone calls
we also have in store will you Eric
Stonestreet feel like you're going to me
no no Chris Brockman has has the his
picks using using things like what are
the words spreads uh-huh totals and
lines lines lines covers for this
weekend for all four games oh all four
games any analytics going on here yes I
got lots of nuggets you've got nuggets
and analytic trends I got analytics by
the way that was a great that was a
great album nuggets in analytics I think
was rush fifth dimension nuggets in
analytics it was great you just eat your
soul where we both came from rush v
images also Mike Dell Tufo has the
weather report foe weekend that's
exciting might tell to folks weather
report it's usually not that good or
usually the flop sweat comes because
they all like kind of evil i me while
I'm doing it so yeah it becomes a little
awkward the flop sweat comes fast I
haven't seen for sure what the weather
is so I'm like you're actually going to
be relied on to get hard information
okay focus drown out the noise and noise
so we just give the give the quality
rather port actually it's now over here
Gason RC and isn't that okay and so I
also gotta make have a start mention
cutter to for you enjoy that when you
had to like Eric Stonestreet right here
on the riches that you ate for for 204
rich if you'd like to chat with him or
any of us that's when we come back here
in the Rich Eisen show alright welcome
back to the Rich Eisen show Eric
Stonestreet spending the hour with us
here the poll question let's check on
results right now brought to you by our
friends a true car when you are trying
to sell or trade in your car you need to
make good choices and with true car
you've got a star on your roster so when
you're ready to sell or trade in your
car check out true car true cash offer
not available in all areas what do you
have over there Chris yeah which
quarterback do you want to see get their
first Super Bowl ring Philip Rivers we
swear now 68% and then go down the
respect to our friend out of respect 13%
for Andrew Luck 10% Patrick mahomes 6%
dak Prescott 3% jer golf where are the
cowboy fans out there
where are the Rams fans 3% for Jared
golf uh-huh that's that's like nuts milk
that's nothing it some thickness so um
but you understand what they of course I
think Phillip Rivers is an awesome dude
I mean he's a competitor and I glad he
was in the AFC West and only legitimizes
our division and I'm thankful that he
was there and I think he's a good guy I
don't want him to win this year
obviously but you would you would you're
rooting for him Sunday right you know I
am I am rooting for him but I think if
if we win tomorrow for a full cleanse of
everything the Patriots need to come to
Arrowhead and we need to beat the
Patriots mean by full cleanse just let
the past be the past and move forward
into this new new era for the Chiefs has
nothing to do with the Patriots it has
everything to do with us but I'm excited
about either of those matchups I think
the Chargers you know came in to
Arrowhead and and they beat us I mean
there's no doubt but I don't think that
will happen twice twice and then of
course he would be a rematch of the
Sunday night game where the Patriots
would be however in your house yeah
they're beat up I mean I am just not
buying in to the Patriots are just did
they're not the same team and I'm not I
know that
Cronk is is a shadow of his computer
she's talking about I know that you're
breaking out just talking about Gronk is
a shadow of his former self I understand
that and who was it was it Charles or
Kurt wondering where the defensive
playmaker was Charles Davis in erawan
wondering where the defensive playmaker
is for the for the Patriots that that
that person doesn't really exist and I'm
like those people never exist until they
become one yeah anyway it works with
newing the playmaker
on the defense for the Patriots has
always been Bill Belichick he puts
people in position right to succeed and
shut down things like he does it like
he's a defensive genius so and Brady is
still you know I know he's a forty
one-year-old diminished returned
supposedly Brady but I don't buy I think
the key on defense
Daunte Hightower didn't play in last
year's playoffs he kind of saw that in
the Super Bowl just gave up lots of
running yards receiving yards points
whatever he's back so he's the play mix
I think he's the playmaker on D Stephon
Gilmore was first-team all-pro this year
in the secondary
of course the McCarney brothers are back
there and there's always again the
Foxborough stuff stuff happened the
pre-snap penalty where you either screw
yourself over when you're going for it
on fourth and fourth in short now you
got a punt or the offsides penalty that
makes it third and long third and
manageable for Brady or the free play
you give Brady or headsets go out well I
mean you know you can I know there's
always that there's that mentality that
Foxborough has the ghost spot yet you
know I'm not buying in any of that no in
that direction of the White House I'm
buying the fact that there's always a
team that does one two three foot
shooting moments that cost them and
you've got to have a clean Jeff yeah
going in and out right you use if you
don't can't make mistakes against them
it's like an MMA match it's like you're
in there battling a guy who's two guys
that are completely qualified to choke
each other out at any given moment right
but what gets a guy choked out isn't
necessarily the the other guy it's you
making mistake
creates the window to be did I kind of
look like I could choke somebody right
there oh it did seem so that's you got a
treat the Patriots like they're there
they're always gonna make the right move
right and then I guess the headset is
the version of the friend of steep Amy
Oh chicks jumping over the top of the
Octagon to just start creating mayhem
that you don't have a spare right but to
set an appropriate analogy as well you
just gotta beat the Colts and then I'll
take you know obviously either one and I
feel I I did I just feel confident I
feel like we can do it knowing that I'm
going to get lit up if that's all right
man I mean you're a fan that's that's
that let's go to the phone lines we ask
for phone calls for Eric and we have
received them Topeka Kansas Mason in
Topeka you're on the Rich Eisen show
their ex Tony what's up Mason hey what's
up guys how you guys doing what's good
hey yeah I was just calling and I guys
have been touching on the Chiefs a lot
Eric I was curious to get your
perspective on the current k-state
situation you know climbing coming in
Snyder retire and you know in ecosan
North Dakota State for he was 72 and six
I believe coach Carson Wentz who was a
zero-star coming there discourtesy he
thought the retirement of Snyder was at
the right time and if you like that
higher well you know it's the right time
for coach Snyder if it was if he feels
that if he feels it and I and I know
coach Snyder well enough to know that he
he puts University and program before
himself and he puts his family before
for a lot of other things so III think
that I said before I yield to coach
Snyder and he decided to retire and I
yield to him on that and with respect to
Coach Klieman coming in um like he said
he's jacked to be there I'm Jack to have
him I haven't reached out to him has he
reached out to you uh not directly in
person but indirectly we've had
conversations through the athletic
director and the head is he aware that
it is should be a first order of
business is to get into contact with you
you know look I love Kansas State and I
think he's you know it's not like we
went out and got the third best coach
and
division we went and got the guy that's
won multiple multiple championships
right he has a good working relationship
with Jean Taylor our athletic director
he's hired a good staff he understands
what he's stepping into at Kansas State
and what it is to be in Manhattan Kansas
he's an Iowa guy meaning he's a Midwest
guy he gets the culture of the climate
of what it is to coach Manhattan which
is like it's an island you know it's in
the middle of nowhere
and he's gonna get guys to want to come
there and play and he's gonna get the
right guys to come there and play
because you come to Manhattan Kansas do
you have to rely on your teammates as
your family because you you don't have
the bright lights of Kansas City it's
two hours away so you reason our teams
have been good is because they they they
commit to each other and becoming
friends with each other on the football
field there's programs that you know
like in the NFL offensive guys don't
even know defensive guys names at Ohio
State and some of those big programs
they're not friends at k-state their
family their friends it's funny every
year you'll text me before the draft
look out for this guy look out for that
guy one of the guys you said that to me
a few years ago was when the Seahawks
drafted Tyler Lockett that guy has
become a bright shining star in Seattle
yeah I also texted some people at the
Chiefs and I said please don't sleep on
Tyler Lockett like he is what do they
say well they bond
I wanted him in Kansas City so bad I
forget who we drafted that could've been
Tyree killer took Marcus Peters so I
don't know who we took second that year
but um Tyler Lockett is unbelievable
unbelievable and his work ethic he is a
consummate Pro and that's what bill
Snyder's reputation was is getting these
guys ready for the next level of their
life whether it's the NFL or whether
it's just being a respectable human
being in society and now you got Kliff
Kingsbury going from the big 12 by way a
quick stop here at USC for like two
weeks and I think what we're seeing is
the combination of Sean mcveigh's young
wunderkind schemer so Tom Landry when
they hired him in 36 so it's not new no
it's not but it's rare that said
uh we're also seeing it has to be what
mahomes has done it has to be something
this is yeah I mean although mahomes
didn't light it up every single game in
the big 12 you know he didn't meet I
don't think he beat k-state maybe he
beat him once somebody he'll tell me but
I mean we handled Holmes when he was
there so I don't know that it's the
cliff it's you know I don't know that
Kliff Kingsbury is gonna take a lot of
the responsibility to Holmes and I don't
know if I think my Holmes would be
gracious and say cliff is a great coach
he's had already come out and said Vince
but you're not you're not coaching up
and teaching mahomes to do some of the
things he's doing he's god-given talent
and it's just like channeling it and
funneling into the right direction now
at the NFL level it's a different deal
because you know you're making reeds and
adjustments and things like that because
you're playing against other NFL players
and in college you can get away with
maybe wing in a little bit more it's
interesting uh while we're having this
conversation at 8:40 for 204 rich we'll
take some more phone calls in a second
Vance Joseph has just been named the
defensive coordinator of the Arizona
Cardinals correct Chris Brockman yeah
and then and also Steve Sarkisian looks
like he's gonna be the OC they're really
yeah how about that a former USC coach
is gonna be the one to try and here's
Josh Rosen a professional even though he
got bounced out of Atlanta and Greg
Williams close to being the jetskis
defensive cordon
yeah but and and you saw what he's done
in Cleveland we'll see what he can do
there in the Jets him and gates have
huge personalities oh my gosh oh yeah
Jets beat riders are gonna have to get
themselves an earful yeah fast all right
let's take one more call Ron in Detroit
you're here on the Rich Eisen show
what's up Ron what's up rich um I was
calling um the situation
the Steelers I have a strong feeling
that the Patriots gonna go after Antonia
Brown because you know the history to go
after um guys who so call have problems
and stuff like that if they play the
Pacers way I think they don't go after
him because that was limping Tom Brady's
career another 2 or 4 years because he
need another weapon out there and I
still
what do you feel about that well Ron and
and thanks to the call he's not a free
agent
so contract he is under contract and I
think what's the name of the warm place
that would have to freeze over yeah hell
yeah before the Patriots get Antonio
Brown and a trade yeah
from Pittsburgh that ain't happening
yeah but I think they'll send him
they'll send him to the other conference
though do you think so yeah I mean we
went over this in the first hour we
could just quickly hit the sack 49 what
do you give up for Antonio Brown well I
mean if you are again here here are the
top five on the clock because you want a
first round selection back for Antonio
Brown Arizona Niners Jets Raiders bucks
you don't think either one of those
teams would would take and and in terms
of you know the Jets that would be a
very difficult sell certainly since Jets
are about to go run run and get levy on
bail exactly bucks the Bucs would take
him and prepare him up with four Mike
Mike Evans with Bruce Arians four for
Jameis just when he they need to get him
successful fast hmm 49ers man I'd
consider that the 49ers yeah they've
been tweet for Jimmy G I saw George
Kittel tweeted I mean he tweeted back
he's like laughed that is good that is
that in levy on bail and is is the
offseason I want Murray and yeah I do
or the bucks - by the way the Bucs have
a ton everybody's got a ton you know and
you know why is the most caps pace I
believe the Colts the Colts have draft
picks coming out of there you know what
and they've got cap space all over the
place and I want to get any more for you
in a few minutes we have left here with
Eric Stonestreet let's play start bench
cut with him as we send him out the door
to his
then to sit down and be quiet or cut off
alright um as always you have three
choices you must start one you must
bench one you must cut one Eric
Stonestreet if the Chiefs advance beyond
this weekend the quarterback you'd least
like to face brady philip breeze start
bench cut okay the one i'd least like to
correct is what you start and then you
go down and okay at least like to face
breeze huh okay then brady then rivers
okay do you think breezes the toughest
or just the faces on another level with
his accuracy I mean I think he is I
think he is Patrick mahomes after
playing in the league for many many
years he's beyond accurate he's just a
gamer a winner
he favorite I just thought you can also
go reverse polarity and just recut Brees
because you want to face him the most
because that means you're in the Super
Bowl well I just thrown that all out
okay no you treat that you treated it
with the spirit with which this is
intended second one home team this
week-end that's most likely to be upset
rams Patriots Saints we three we took
you guys out we take your Chiefs out of
it thank you
start bench cut Rams Patriots Saints
team most likely to be upset this
weekend at home
Rams Patriots Saints yeah it's tough to
go in that regard but everybody's
jumping on that charges bandwagon man
keep doing it everyone jump aboard all
right last one biggest fan faux pas at
an any NFL game this week start bench
cut leaving the game before it's over
leaving your seats during game play
bathroom concessions or any we're
wearing apparel from teams that are not
playing oh my gosh that's the most
annoying thing that's Brockman's pet
thank you it is so annoying
I don't understand it yeah it's like
okay thanks for the information bro
thanks thanks for letting us all know
that you root for the Jets at this
Patriots Chargers game
like like who cares exactly it's such a
weird thing to do thank you you just may
as well just wear a jersey that says
sports okay you start that no I wouldn't
start that because that's so beyond it
doesn't even register on my okay getting
up in front of me during play is real
real problem it's why I sit where I sit
at the Kings right up front I'm a glass
nobody gets in front of me except the
referee uh so that's a start
yeah and then leaving leaving the game
early is it's kind it's you know it's I
know the players don't care but I think
it's like disrespectful you're either in
or you're out in or out and then I go
with the Jersey thing even though it's
probably the thing I think it's the
dumbest right it it doesn't bother me
the most because it's so off the charts
dumb start bench cut with with Eric
Stonestreet here on the program this is
a blast having you on here yeah I love
it it's great you guys having here yeah
I think k-state plays tonight against
Iowa State right okay I that I don't
have an answer to a sketball
I don't know so again you're home I'm
home
I know it's over/under number of people
in your house three and a half watching
with you two people me and one other
under oh you're locked in I don't know I
didn't even get the invitation no no
well you come no it's all right wasn't
fishing for anything you you absolutely
can come because you understand how to
watch a game like here's the thing I
don't want to invite people over and
then be tone would be quiet the whole
time because then I look like the
controlling one but I'm like well look
you know how I like to watch the game so
why wouldn't you come in with that
respect and be like let's be quiet we
forgot to ask that for start beds cut
because that of it a start right there
yeah it's like all right so it's just
you're tightening the playoff rope
you're more than welcome to come I'm
gonna have I'm gonna make I brought I'm
gonna make some hamburgers I mean people
you know like gonna be surprised that
I'm not in Kansas City but I very you
know I don't think there's I'll be there
there's maybe some more football games
to be played that's what I'm that's what
I'm thinking
why am I so sick inside right now
there's just something burning inside me
that I can't understand it I didn't
called the game is finally here I know I
just wanna I just wanna wish all those
guys luck
Mitch Schwartz you know best right
tackle oh yeah you made pro a pro he
finally got the respect he but he didn't
make the Pro Bowl no fish did though I
mean it's it's it's I think it's the
left tackle love of the left tackle
tackle bias because the blindside whole
thing but we all know that like the
right tackle that they put their guys
over at the right tackle because of the
left tackle I think watching that Monday
Night Football game with you the Chiefs
Broncos you the thing you said the most
was just ask mom Miller who's the
toughest guy to ask Bob you go ask he
it's like I'm just like you wanted me to
come on the air the next day and call
von Miller just to ask him to listen
it's it's anyway Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience